[Music]
hallo YouTube just lost my friends
this is guns on here welcome to the
thirty fifth episode of my chest trap
series in this episode I'm going to show
you a wonderful high profile trap in the
caro-kann two nights variation from the
black respective the opening arises
after the following model evil c6 white
can't start with either of the night
moon let's say in the game
white continue with Knight to c3 and
after the move defy he need played
Knight to f3 which transpose into the
caro-kann two Knights attack
it's amazing that few years back I have
made a video on the two Knights attack
from the white respect II and now we are
sitting on the other side of the coin
however stay tuned guys as during the
video I am going to point out as a wide
how you can avoid this trap and still
obtain a good position from the white
respective okay the main line start with
Bishop to g4 pinning down the night and
after White's
obvious response as three blacks idea is
he wants to capture this night and after
Queen captures f3 yes indeed white is
more than happy as he get the bishop
pair early in the opening but on the
other hand after the movie six black has
get rid of this bad bishop which gives
him ample opportunity in the upcoming
middle game now by far the most popular
choice is D 3 which is favored by Bobby
Fischer himself however as a white if
you really want to over this line then
my recommendation is
you should definitely consider the mood
default and I have attached a simple
line in the PG in which can give you a
great direction how you can continue and
obtain a good position okay of a trappy
line start with the Moody three and
after that black plays this obvious move
Bishop to b4 pinning down the c3 Knight
here there are two popular choices by
white the main lines start with Bishop
to d2 however there is an interesting
trap exists if you opponent continue it
Queen to g3 which in fact happened in
the few games right obviously
counter-attack on g7 but guess watch
here comes the moon which sets up a nice
cunning trap and that start with Knight
to f6
so now black is all set to castle on the
Kings side and somewhere down the line
d4 is a big threat so if White has come
this far then he has to take on g7
attacking the rook in the corner well
after this I am afraid by force white is
losing and you definitely want to pause
this video and find out by yourself how
this can happen over the ball well the
first move is very obvious rook to g8
attacking the Queen Queen has the only
square to go and after that did you spot
it yup this winning move d4 getting the
whole piece well some of you may ask
hang on that's not possible
because white can counter-attack with a
three but here the surprise springs to
the white cam yes black has this nice
cute move
bish up to a phage attacking to sports
and by force black is winning the whole
piece
so that's the reason why white continued
it Bishop to d2 unpinning the night
immediately but again the thing I like
most about this line is black can
continue with default attacking the
night and what has to be careful as if
he moved the night then the d2 bishop
drops and his king will be misplaced
so accordingly night to be even is a
fitting reply
supporting the d2 bishop now here black
has tried many moves but I'm going to
propose this very cunning reply Queen to
b6 which sets up a very nasty trap
so as you can see there is x-ray on b2
and accordingly as per the database
Queen to g3 has been played highest ly
from this position now before we look at
it the important point I like to mention
that if white try to protect on b2 with
the move b3 which happen in few games
black can obtain a decent position with
the following sequence Knight to e7
planning to Castle queenside and when
wide course for the same with Bishop to
e2 you can stop him castling by Bishop
captures d2 Knight captures d2 and now
Queen to b4 one of the game in the
database continue with rook to d1 so now
indeed white is protecting the night and
ready to castle but after castle castle
and the MU fi black obtained a long
lasting advantage idea is very simple
playing the move fo and create pressure
on the Queen side and in the game white
indeed play the moon fo but after black
snakes reply that is B Phi a captures B
Phi and C captures be Phi
not only black obtain a clear pass porn
on the a file but in the mix he has this
weakness on a c2 which altogether gives
black a hell of a good position so let's
see what is happening after the move
Queen to g3 once again counter attacking
on g7 and before I [ __ ] I like you to
pause this video and find out a move
which can create a nasty trap for the
white cap
are you ready did you find this superb
move back to f6
completely cam beating the g7 bond and
mind you white dare not to take it
why what happens if he continued with
Queen captures g7 which is the obvious
response attacking to pieces and black
cannot defend both of them so what can
be the more neutral than this well guess
what white straight away enter into the
black trappy territory and to illustrate
the whole trap I like to show you a
model game between two 2300 plus rated
opponent where black continued with rook
to g8 sacrificing the whole night and
after Queen captures f6 did you see the
point behind sacrificing the night yes
the same old story
last time of a bishop goes to the f8 and
this time of a bishop goes to the e7
attacking the Queen and after that by
force black is winning the whole
exchange it is not surprising that
within the 14 moves of the game black
obtained the winning position Quinto at
6 happened and after the obvious
response Queen captures be too wide
gives this one thread Queen captures at
7 but that can be safely negotiate with
rope to a fade and finally after Bishop
to e2 and the move Queen captures even
it is pretty clear that black obtained
the exchange within the opening stage
and it is just matter of playing
accurately to claim the full point
you can check out rest of the game in
the PG in which black winning quite
easily that's it guys remember at this
position if you opponent continue with
Queen to g3 give him this ultimate shock
with Knight to f6 and after the obvious
response Queen captures g7 it is only
white who find himself on the losing end
within the opening stage thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I'll meet you
in my next episode very soon bye Anne
take care